remember that story that they told us
about in training
about george washington's first female
spy during the revolution
they called her agent 355
because they didn't want the world to
know her real name
but her legacy lives on jessica you were
number one on my ballot at the critic's
choice for tammy fay
obsessed
thank you and i'm kind of obsessed with
your like dress matching your background
with the fresh flowers
amazing but i think we both kind of go
together as well like you've got the
nice spring motif are we ready for a new
year
i'm definitely ready to get outside and
be with people i hear you um first of
all i absolutely love this movie it was
so refreshing to see and what i loved
hearing was that you called a lot of
these actresses and asked them it's my
understanding what role would they like
to play how rewarding was it for you
conceptualizing this film and being able
to do that and bring this team together
and why the team that you chose yeah it
was really important for me i mean
making the film i was like i don't know
that anything has been made like this
where women you know there's an ensemble
action film where it's not a joke or a
comedy that they're taught like we take
it seriously
and then also i wanted the actresses to
be the owners of the film and the bosses
of the films um to own the work to make
it outside of studio system and to make
it for the fraction of what it costs to
make a normal movie like this and so
yeah it was very important to me and you
had parody as well
yes
yes so why why was that important to you
well it's i mean i i believe that a
person should get paid for
the work that they put into a project so
that doesn't necessarily mean in terms
that
um every project you do you get paid the
same because you know i just did a film
um
with ray fines
his time commitment was longer than mine
but per day
we were paid the same right and so
that's what makes sense you get paid
equal pay for equal work um one of my
favorite scenes was when you played that
sort of cat and mouse um with diane in
the very beginning what i liked about
this film is you really felt the fights
were happening you didn't feel like
there was a lot of special effects or
cutaways where you didn't really feel
like how did it feel for you because it
looked painful it was beautiful
i mean i really threw myself into
everything we we trained for a little
over three weeks before we started
shooting learning all the fights we did
weapons training we did stunt
choreography harness work i mean i did
the leaps off the buildings at one point
i got sent to the hospital because i hit
my head on a marble floor like it really
i mean it wasn't um a situation where
we're like okay let's walk in here and
then
um have someone else do the work for us
we really showed up everyone showed up
and put their sweat into this project
i know you said in the past that you
appreciate watching characters on screen
that are doing extraordinary things and
going beyond what they thought they were
capable of what was your moment as an
actress where you felt like you went
beyond or even within this film where
you felt like you went beyond even what
you imagined well this i mean everything
about this film is beyond what i thought
was cape i was capable of we put it
together from scratch i mean raise the
money on our own but then also i was
self-financing at a certain point like
paying for the script and
um there were
many off many times where people's reps
would call and say you guys aren't
really making that film are you because
we'd have like okay this is our start
date and people in the industry just
never thought it was going to happen
they thought oh it's this novelty it's
this like
you know but it could never really
happen i mean it's really really hard to
put a pill together
so yeah
every day every day was like that for me
how would mason maya work together
because this reminded me a little bit of
xerodark 30 it had a little bit of that
vibe
well she was the a consultant on our
film so it makes sense that um there is
that vibe uh well i think mace would be
the one who would get out there and do
the the day-to-day work uh maya for sure
would be um
telling her what to do maya would be the
boss
and mace would be following her
directions
interesting i thought it might be the
other way around
maya for sure maya's everybody's boss
okay got it
um
it was such a pleasure i wish i had more
time chatting with you but
congratulations on everything you've
been doing wonderful so much wonderful
to see you and thank you for your nice
words about tammy fay
absolutely loved it championing that
movie all over the place i watched it
back to back i watched it and then
watched it again right after so please
keep making more films for women thank
you
i like the new team we're the 355. i
first wanted to ask you if you saw
spider-man before we get to talking
about this movie i i have not i actually
have not yeah for me it's a tough thing
but but i get there i do make it
is that what it is he's tough to watch
right it's just i noticed in the trailer
that he's wearing the the the mask less
and less and it just i i like i deal
with it better when i just see the
spider-man as a whole so maybe for the
next film
i was wondering if you were going to
show up in it well that's the problem
you know they don't call they don't
write
when are we going to see you in another
mcu movie is it going to be sooner or
later wakanda forever
i haven't known the answer to that
question since 2010.
[Laughter]
it's still going or are you being like
an andrew garfield no they haven't
called they haven't called and then
you're all over it
thanks for spoiling the film
oh my gosh so i loved this film and i
know the last time that you worked with
jessica was on the martian how did that
call go when she called you um because i
know with some of the actresses she said
what kind of role do you want to play
did she do that with you or did she just
say hey
buddy you're in this film it was great
because
she called and said look
i want to i want to do this movie and i
want it to be a unique experience i want
it to be about the actors and i want the
actors
and the you know the creative team to
just really come up with the story and
here's what here's what we got so far um
go and have a conversation with simon
kinberg the writer director and and then
see what you think and you know i think
you could play this role and then with
simon
um
it was really great because
it was very collaborative and that's how
it was for the rest of the shoot
we were all encouraged to sort of
bring whatever we wanted to bring to the
characters and and as a result i think
they
the whole film developed um but it was
it was a really uniquely collaborative
experience i just say that you and
jessica have so much chemistry on screen
can you compare your chemistry between
because you've said that you and mackie
are very opposite and that works i hope
you mentioned this to jessica when you
interview her i think that's all i
talked about nice for her to get that
feedback
that's all i said oh great um she's
always been one of my favorite actors
and and again
um
she's very committed and she really
shows up and she loves
she loves acting she loves um characters
and like singing her teeth into it and
is super dedicated and and so that that
only motivates me usually when i'm
around somebody like that then i then i
get excited and i want to get in there's
and and and then when you have those two
people kind of coming together then i
feel like
you you can you can have something
special and different and and i feel i
feel the same way about anthony um i i
loved
a lot of movies that he's done
before he even joined the mcu and um and
again it's like once once you see
something works and there's enough trust
there between you then you kind of start
guessing each other's moves and and
that's when it becomes super fun and
then do you have to stay unpredictable
and then yeah and then and then you have
to somehow find a way to surprise them
uh
and keep them on on your toes on their
toes um so
so i think you've mentioned and this
sort of surprised me that you got to do
action types of action in this movie
that you've never done before
how how was that and can you talk about
that well we had we had this period of
month-long training beforehand and and i
thought that always helps when you have
and a lot of times you don't get that
time and and because then you can go on
the day and then you you take whatever
you've rehearsed and you can sort of
improvise a little bit around it
yeah there was a different level of sort
of
uh
rawness and brutality to the to the
sequences that we were learning that
i just was was different for me um and
um and so i embraced that i don't like
to harp on the fact that this is
primarily a female cast i don't like to
sort of you know broadcast it i think it
should just be the norm but how was the
energy how did it compare and i know
you've mentioned that the 355 could take
down winter soldier what is his weakness
that they're exploiting
well the vibe was things just get done
[Laughter]
they just get done a lot faster a lot
more effectively and generally
everything runs a lot better and
smoother
but other than that how did the 355 take
down the winter soldier is that that i
think you mentioned it in another
somebody else you were talking to i
think it was comic-con you were like oh
they could take down winter soldier for
sure how are they taking him down
i mean probably by just having a
conversation
and just saying buddy
it's okay you know
we've all we we've all been vulnerable
at one point or another you can be
vulnerable too
i don't know i'm just saying i'm trying
to be creative about it but you're
laughing so it's working it's brilliant
that was a great answer are you kidding
me
no cause winter soldier doesn't really
you know a lot of his problems were like
not confronting his past and not talking
about his emotions and things and i feel
like he could use a little bit of that
winter soldiers probably been solved by
the women of the three five five i love
this um before i let you go i have to
ask i'm obsessed first of all i love
when you're talking about anthony mackie
and his projects i loved monday i loved
endings beginnings i love them oh thank
you for saying
that but i love all the different
choices that you've made as an actor and
now i cannot wait to see pam and tommy i
mean i am beyond how wild is it like can
you just tease anything about it i know
it's coming out soon well february 2nd
on hulu listen it's a wild story to look
back on um and re-examine i think in a
lot of ways i mean i was very young i
was still in romania when that happened
right it was like 94 or 95 or 96 97 but
i think over the years
people have heard things about it or
they feel like they know what happened
or you know the media and
the audience's culprits all kind of
threw their point of views on it and
uh said what they said about it and and
and there's actually a lot to the story
that i feel like we don't know and and
and we're you know we're in a place now
where we're looking back and kind of
uh
looking at our perspectives of it then
and and now as it's still a very
relevant timely um story and so i'm
excited for people to see it um
and um you know we did we did the best
we could what is your personal number
one spy skill what quality do you have
that you speak
most stealth i guess actors to some
extent have to learn how to
you know pretend and um i suppose spies
and undercover agents have to do that so
so hopefully some of the acting skills
would help me out but
i'm not an agent i'm a therapist they
thought i would give you my secrets do
you have secrets first of all love this
film love that is very different from
things that we've seen before in the spy
genre what i thought was really unusual
was that jessica actually called you to
ask you what kind of thing you would
like to see for your character it wasn't
like they sent you a script and said
would you like to do the movie
and you said you wanted your character
to be a fish out of water
why did you decide that well because i
when she called me and she and simon had
this idea but there was not even a first
draft of the script and and she she
asked me what would you like to play in
this genre what do you imagine now that
we have the opportunity to
all of us involved
our ideas and bring things into the
project
and i don't know immediately in that
conversation
it came to my mind
that this character of the fish out of
water we have not seen a lot in this in
this genre and i thought
it's important that everyone is really
good at what they do and
this group of women they are all very
smart very clever and really really good
at
many things but they cannot be great at
everything
so i thought
let me be the one that doesn't want to
be there that doesn't belong there she's
a great psychologist she's used to work
with agents
in her city while she's raising her kids
she works with post-traumatic stress
disorder she can know when somebody's
lying she's very good but she doesn't
want to be in that mission and something
happens and she's forced to be in that
mission
i thought that could bring some humor
into the story and also some members of
the audience could identify with that
and say okay that would be me in that
situation running away covering my face
with a rough flooring bag
being totally terrified right
it was brilliant i think you could pitch
more movies now because i love
your she was the heart of the movie and
you're right she was extremely funny
um i also wanted to ask you what do you
think graziella what do you think her
special her most special skill is that
she brings to the group
i think she has
a probably the skills of
knowing when somebody is hiding
something and she's very affectionate
she's a great mom she she for example
the relationship that she has with edgar
and you wonder what has happened between
them like she has helped him as an agent
that was probably really traumatized
from a lot of things that have that he
has seen
or maybe even
some other bonding that they might have
i think that's kind of floating there
but
her skills are more more subtle and and
actually she's needed in the group she's
nearly in the mission because of that
accident because of happens with what
happens with edgar but i love that you
see this arc in the character where you
can see the transformation where she
starts
enjoying that kind of life and that
adrenaline and probably if the movie
goes well and there is a second one
i think she will want to be involved in
that
and
combine her life as a mother with with
that other crazy life
uh you led me into my next question
because i was going to ask you if there
is another movie and i hope there is
another movie uh who would you like to
recruit uh i don't know i think that
would not be for me to say but for all
of us to
get together and plan
but
that would be amazing of course that
would be amazing her character from
hitman's bodyguard's wife
done i mean
for me anything with her because you
know she's like another sister for me
so
we're really really close actually i
just talked to her an hour ago
did you
so that's a great idea and i love that
you worked with edgar again that's
that's amazing was it your idea to play
a mother i know i'm congratulations on
paramount parallel mothers by the way
your award at the venice film festival
you've gotten so much recognition for
this you've had such a busy year but was
that your idea to have her play a mother
in this film
uh that was important for jessica and
for myself for both of us to to include
that in the film like
it's at least one of us had to be a
mother so we could show also the
the difficulties of combining that kind
of job um
that involves a lot of risks
with with being a mother and for gracial
that is her total priority and
even if you would see her work her her
job done from home how that would still
be hard to combine like to to see those
struggles and those difficulties it was
important for us like at least one of us
if graciela's special skill
if she has her own special skills what
would you say you yourself what would
your friends and family say is your own
special skill
hey i love this question um
i think it would be
about knowing when somebody's lying when
somebody's hiding something
so even yourself you know that yeah
i might not know what it is of course i
wish i knew but knowing when somebody's
hiding something yes do you think you're
very good at that i think so
sometimes i don't like having that those
skills because sometimes it's
you feeling no again i'm getting this
thing and most times is right
but
no but it's okay so it's better to have
it i'll handle the guns
are you in therapy i should be we are
kicking this off this is the first big
release of 2022 why do you think this is
the perfect movie to kick off the new
year
oh it's just so entertaining i have to
say i'm ready to
let off some steam after this rather
depressing holiday season um you know
and it's it's just it's fun i i also
think it's it's quite smart
i think it's just the right
moment for us to go back to
the movies and just have a fun raid and
and let all those um
depressing news wash up over a shoulders
yeah
um i found marie
when i was looking at all the different
action scenes because it was there was
so much action in it it almost doesn't
let up through the whole movie but marie
is the character i would least want to
fight with because she's so scrappy her
style
and i love the scene between you and
jessica especially sort of like the the
cat and mouse scene um can you just talk
a little bit about kind of crafting
those fight scenes it felt very real it
didn't feel like a lot of special
effects so just sort of like the
intensity of preparing for those
um yeah we had a lot of training for
this um
part of of what i wanted to bring to the
character was this you know that that
german that sense of being german where
you associate that with you know a
certain discipline a certain
preciseness
um and marie was very much written like
that right she has nothing to lose no
attachments whatsoever it doesn't matter
how you get there as long as you get
there um that relentlessness like just
always on and
um you know i try to bring that into the
fight scenes um the stunt coordinator
that they assigned to me
you know her and i had a very tight
relationship because i wanted her
whatever wasn't me to fight like my
character would you know and i think
sometimes
that gets overlooked you know you have
like the actor doing her thing and then
they have
stunned people and it looks like
two different
people trying to you know in the same
scene and we really talked about how
like what you responded to like the
scrapping is like it doesn't matter just
get up let's go you know it doesn't
matter if it's pretty or not just like
you know that
wiry quality that's exactly how it felt
and you can tell when you watch movies
when there's a difference between oh
there's the stunned person and there's
the axe or dude you never felt that i'm
gonna take you back almost 20 years to
national treasure the chase when you
were chased in that scene can you talk
about like the compare like the
evolution of how fight scenes have
evolved and sort of take me back to sort
of maybe the preparation for that versus
this and how how you've evolved as an
action
you know doing these types of scenes
this felt very different because it was
a
you know the whole character was that
action part so like i said like it felt
like
everything
my character was doing
was informed through that action whether
that's loading a gun or hiding from
being shot at right so
it was more of a complete training it
took really truly did it wasn't about
getting a six-pack you know what i'm
saying it was about
getting that physicality right for the
character
so it took it took many weeks to like
make that all happen because i've never
changed a gun magazine thingy and it's
not really not that easy
in my opinion so
you mentioned
being very german and what i love about
this cast
is that it is an international cast and
that you do speak i mean there's
different languages spoken the film and
that's another thing that i liked about
the authenticity of it is that sometimes
you know somebody will be in japan it'll
be in a different country but then speak
english and you're like they would never
speak english with each other so you can
talk about can you talk about
um how important it was for you to sort
of bring that into the film and it being
this cast of women that are from all
over
i mean i i just think that the times
have changed you know i think audiences
are
smarter and they don't want to
feel like they're being duped um any
more you know we had that same
issue a problem uh for glorious bastards
for example you know where
we had an entire script really in german
and in french and how do we make this
sounding authentic and yet make it
accessible to an american audience
so i i think that um
the times have changed in the sense that
generations want to actually they're
looking for that
exotic
escape as well you know they want to
hear those languages
they're not as
scared of maybe reading a subtitle or
you know and they want to be transported
into a different country so that's part
of it i think you know and
i'm hoping that especially in these
weird pandemic times that's actually
really exciting to feel like you are
you are traveling with us to a different
country and you're going to hear all
those different languages marie has
obviously i think her scrappiness is her
special skill and her fighting ability
but what what do you think your friends
and your people close to you would say
is your special skill like what do you
bring to your group um that would be
your own personal special skill
i'm a really good organizer of things
you know like people look to me my
friends are always i'm like a problem
solver like um
there's something to be planned
organized get everybody to the same
place for a party
make sure
people get called and followed up on
like that's like me or somebody has a
problem
they usually come to me and i
have us like a more level-headed um
way out of it you know
which they would say is very german
there's a scene in the movie that i
loved i think it was my favorite scene
in the movie where you all sort of the
355 gets together and sits down for the
first time for a meal and you sort of
compare stories of your first mission
what was your first acting job or your
first super memorable
job that you remember from from when you
started
well my very first job
i
you know i'd never been in front of the
camera i'm in a moving camera and i so
was completely green i was still in
acting
school
theater class and i played a girl that
was in a wheelchair after a car accident
and i had prepared for that role i mean
weeks and weeks and weeks and i couldn't
believe my luck it was a french a french
tv
show really bad tv show and you know all
these ideas of what i could bring to the
character
and i just remember getting there like
an hour before my call time and i'm just
being so nervous and
you know in my head thinking that that's
how i'm going to get into this character
and then you know they're finally
calling me to set
and it was over like nobody paid any
attention to me because i was like a day
player right and
they just okay say lines and this is it
done
and i couldn't believe i was so
disappointed and devastated because i
felt like my artistic soul was just
violated
um
that i you know i remember that like so
much um
and then my real first movie was was
dennis hopper and he played my dad and
so
i remember that as being a defining
moment in my life of course and he truly
taught me everything and i mean
everything from like the most basic
things like
if you can't see the camera
you know the camera can't see you
because i was so green and i went to
theater school so i didn't i didn't have
any you know camera training or anything
like that
you